hey so you're like you've gotten these
like huge cosigns from guys like KD guys
like Kevin uh obviously I already said
Kevin Durant who's a Phoenix Sun now by
the way
um LeBron James riding around listening
to your music like for you like when you
see LeBron is like
just a fan like what's that feel like to
know like arguably the greatest player
of all time is like extremely tapped in
that that feels great yeah yeah coming
from where I come from you know what I'm
saying it's it's amazing you know I'm
saying I'm not used to like I'm always
used to like being dope but like people
not knowing about it right it's almost
like those cosines mean a lot more than
like some of these industry cosigns that
you kind of feel like you need to be
like solidified right it's like [__]
that hey KD and Lebron are bumping my
[__] [__] what you think you know what
I'm saying facts and it's naturally
organic you know what I'm saying they
they they they feel the music you know
what I'm saying so that [__] that [__]
is beautiful I feel like I might have
seen you in the studio with Katie am I
tripping nah you ain't tripping man you
ain't tripping no I'm saying we KD KD um
he been behind the scenes working with
me and ran on some things you know me me
and ran so so you know me and Rance I
mean KD we like you know got some things
cooking up y'all can expect
some things some powerful well listen
for people who don't know Kevin Durant
did have a record label back in the day
when he first was at OKC he did have a a
go at the music industry
um
is he trying to spin the block
and I wouldn't say trying I'm gonna say
he's spinning the block heavy yeah with
Ransom and 38 Special yeah I would say
that you know so did you guys sign to do
like a like an album with him no we just
he just we just added right now we just
you know we just um
we just build them
you know would you sign with Kevin
Durant
I don't I don't I don't really like even
the word sign would you partner with KD
on a project I would definitely part are
you guys partnering on a project that's
a strong yeah that's that's definitely
what's happening we definitely
partnering so you Ransom Kevin Durant
partnering on the body of work yeah
wow yeah and Katie's got a great ear for
this rap [__] so like yeah he does
how much input does he have does he help
him oh no
picking beats yeah yeah Four Hands On
and On You know I'm saying giving all a
lot of input you know he got a good
solid ear you know we all come from the
same qualified as what we like is for
sure for sure so you know you know uh
that's how that is you know and we just
running through reaching out grabbing up
the production and that's amazing that's
a big deal you know what I'm saying so
you got to come to Phoenix now I
definitely do you want to come to the
hometown man yeah post it I'm supposed
to be going out there sometime soon and
[__] we got some great recording studios
out there that's where DMX recorded a
lot of [__] and Little Wayne did the
card of three out there and hey Z you
know that we got we got some good spots
to lay down some uh
some partnered albums with Kevin Durant
that's for sure oh no yeah I've already
hit but you got to come out for the
playoffs because you know we're making
the I mean we're gonna be in we're going
to the finals you know what I'm saying
as long as Katie's healthy as long as
his foot is okay and he don't slip on
the court anymore we'll be all right
word up do you okay so if you're if
you're working with KD are you
automatically like that's your squad
whatever team he's on hell yeah yeah
so your son's fan basically
right hell yeah I realize you gotta
realize like before before NBA started
supporting me and [__] you know I never
really watched Sports so you were never
a big Sports guy anyway never was a
sports guy I can't even tell you who
went to the Super Bowl last year
I don't even know who won a championship
last year you know what a year before
that no no that is a life I wish I had I
let so much [__] that I can't control
stress me out so much because I'm such a
sports fanatic and I gamble on so much
[__] I'm like I don't know any of these
guys I'm not playing in the games
but somehow my life is so wrapped up
into
it's like some gang [__] like I'm a I'm
a [__] Suns fan like I've given so
much of my money to Phoenix Suns [__]
like if you were to go to my closet ran
I probably have 100 jerseys it's really
sickening like but I'm just glad that
I've already bought three KD jerseys
they haven't gotten delivered yet but I
can't wait shout out to the sons man I
went to Katie's house once
Freddy Gibbs during the pandemic had his
uh birthday there it was like a little
barbecue
and I was wearing a Sons Rex Chapman
Jersey and I got I talked with Katie for
about 45 minutes and he was giving me
props and
I was like I've told him then I was like
hey man
would you ever come to Phoenix he had
just went to Brooklyn you know so how
like Phoenix I was like man look we'll
have you buddy anytime look it ended up
working out I'm gonna have to give you
my jerseys to get them signed though